joining us now former Hillary Clinton
advisor Phillipe Ramos and former
Clinton advisor dick morris and the
author of the new book rogue spook
salute Eileen and along with Wall Street
Journal columnist Kim stressful all
right I brought a special prop I'm not a
prop person but I have a gavel and in
case things get really nasty between
Morrison grayness don't worry you're in
on this action too I'm not a man of
violence all right let's start with
Morris here because dick first of all I
want to congratulate you you're wearing
the britt hume Boca ratone sweater
tonight so you you already win points
tell me about this idea and we heard it
from trey gowdy that at least part of
this dossier part of the information in
it came from Sid Blumenthal then we'll
talk about Cody share yeah I said this
on your show last week that they
couldn't publish the negative research
that Shira and Blumenthal did under
Charon Blumenthal's names because they
were so discredit on Trump on Trump so
they laundered it through steel they
found steel who has a excellent record
as a foreign service person head of the
Russia Bureau at mi6 for decade and he
had a good relationship with the FBI and
they felt that if they laundered it to
steal when it was presented his steals
work there would be a better chance of
it being taken seriously and I believe
that most of the dossier was written by
Shira and Blumenthal first from knowing
Hillary they are the class a dirty ops
black ops people she goes to and and
Hillary at one point called me and the
96th campaign and said I really want you
to get to know Sidney Blumenthal and
then bill followed it up and said did
Hillary talk to you about Sidney and I
said yeah and then every time I met with
Sidney every week I would call Hillary
and he was the dirty tricks operative I
remember I wanted to know doles position
on something it was our opponent and he
wasn't saying so I asked Blumenthal who
was allegedly a journalist
Yorker - asked all the question and dole
answered it and I used it a negative ad
now this doesn't mean that he's
necessarily the source of the dossier I
mean the fact that he did all this stuff
in the 90s how do we jump to the
conclusion that he necessarily did this
and I want to get Philippe on this
Philippe you know look that you heard
what Gowdy said Sid obviously has a long
history he was so he was so radioactive
that even Rahm Emanuel banned him from
the Obama White House didn't want any
part of him in the White House because
he believed that Blumenthal was behind
all the negative stuff that came out
about Obama in the 2008 campaign which
he they were right about so what up what
of this well let me say that I agree
with something Dick said which is that
chrissteele is a renowned mi6 agent and
Foreign Service agent if his theory is
correct as to why they funneled or
launder it through him then you've got a
problem because I think dick does
inadvertently gave credence to the rest
of the dossier no trey gowdy trey gowdy
didn't say who it was but let's just
stipulate that his come on but just okay
let's say 7:00 noon yesterday I've never
heard of Cody Shearer no one's gonna
believe that I I just have never heard
the name SID
I think dick knows with the Clintons as
long as I thought I wasn't fired by them
but the more important thing is the low
blow Sid you know what is a lot more of
a character than you're just you're okay
I'm not defending him but I think the
most important thing is the notion that
the dossier was written Sid Blumenthal
is crazy
that's not what happened chrissteele
wrote the dossier chrissteele let's get
to Kim and Devin Nunez has said that
much in it is real Kimberly go ahead
let's talk about Christopher steel for a
little bit because the importance of the
Grassley memo today is that it provides
proof information that mr. steel went to
the FBI and and supposedly he was so
worried about the country and Donald
Trump and yet he broke FBI cardinal
rules he undermined the FBI the FBI
headed Mon
him not to speak to anyone and yet he
went running out to sit down with Glenn
Simpson and opposition research firm and
briefed all of their buddies in the
press in September in order to create
negative headlines against Donald Trump
he blew the FBI's operation put it out
there in the public and and then the
Hillary Clinton campaign capitalized it
on it and the days following so tell me
how we view this man as a stand-up mi6
agent that can be trusted if he
understood the rules of the game he
would not have broken all of the FBI's
rules he strikes me as a political
operator who was by the way on record of
saying that he was absolutely opposed to
Donald Trump ever becoming president
dick I think that no I'm not defending
Christopher steel I do want to point out
though that steel said in the deposition
on the civil lawsuit that he got a lot
of his material from an outside source
unsolicited he said and let's remember
that this guy who was the bureau chief
at mi6 where a dossier that said
prostitutes were peeing on the bed that
Steve cone is the guy who arranged the
collusion intone had never been to
Prague where it took place
said Carter pay the guy who was serving
a 40-year sentence for pedophilia in the
gulag was the one who had Hillary's DNC
80% of that dossier is so clearly alive
and 47% is reporting Trump has a big
problem 40% of it is the story about
between dick arts and Devon Nunez giving
credence to the dossier
could we hear what the 20% is that's
true yeah guys guys guys Bob Muller is
gonna tell us
this is standard is this a standard now
you can spy on an American citizen with
a document that his Providence is
unclear whose agent behind the document
has violated the norms of intelligence
by sharing this information with the
press before is even looks like
submitted to the FISA Court in the in
the FBI itself knew that
this the origin of this document was
funded by a political opposition not
just an opposition person but the
opposition candidate if you can spine an
American on that basis I find it to be
terrifying I don't care if you're a
Republican Democrat or somewhere but
that's not the base that is terrifying
the basis for the warrant as we've
learned is that George papadopolis the
coffee boy oh yeah okay that's a real
reason the coffee boy boasts all about
our great years and why he is with it
once the fights of the basis once the
FISA warrant was granted Carter page was
listened in on and every 90 days they
were neutered for thermodyne phoney
based no no info need you can't renew it
unless it's based on what the 90 days
have provided the same the great week go
ahead then they do conclude that the
dossier was a significant part if not
the instrumental part of the FISA
application without which that FISA
application would not have been filed
McCabe did say that in in the testimony
on Capitol Hill the closed-door he said
that in the Grassley graham referral
which by the way quotes from the FISA
application it's the first time we've
seen text from the FISA application said
that the FISA application were lied
quote heavily on two pieces of
information on the dossier and then on a
yahoo news article that was inspired by
Christopher Steele as well and meant to
suggest that somehow there was
corroboration and by the way the the
Grassley Graham referral also and this
is very important reveals to us that
even Comey admitted in front of the
Senate Judiciary that we have evidence
that they didn't weren't able to
independently verify the dossier or this
article oh he was absolutely I call me
said that and so when he was asked why
they nonetheless ran with it he said
well because Christopher Steele's a
reliable guy
Ron Johnson Ron Johnson swap gonna miss
Devon Nunez swung and missed Grassley is
taking the baton from them and he's
trying the same thing to muddy the water
we should talk about the text messages
let's go to story I had that Perot
can I point out investigated his
daughter's fiance okay didn't want his
daughter marrying you
Felipe's it's gonna hit me with it
alright fantastic